49ers getting guys healthy
right zero and zero
you get them all healthy and you assume
they're gonna be healthy that's one of
the things i love about the offseason we
always assume that everyone's gonna be
healthy because we have no idea who's
gonna get injured and when and for how
long so we just go into it thinking
everyone's going to be healthy if the
49ers can keep everyone healthy even if
jimmy garoppolo is still the quarterback
chris this is a team that can be
dangerous and disruptive in the nfc no
question no question i mean we saw them
be dangerous and disruptive with you
know less than quarterback play and a
ton of injuries you know at the end of
the year and and really lost some
heartbreaking games where they outplayed
teams and kind of just lost because they
made bad mistakes and did bad things i
mean that's that's really all there is
to it so i mean i'm certainly not
counting out the 49ers especially with
you know kyle shanahan and his
creativity on the offensive side of the
ball and yeah we know when jimmy
garoppolo is healthy they're damn good
you look at their offense and go hey
there there's not much there we gotta
look at you know the receivers a tight
end it's all in place could maybe they
get another running back in this shuffle
because we've seen that they you know
can get banged up and that's a very
important position but i don't know if
there's anything you know dramatic that
needs to be done there
the the thing i at least look at with
them trent williams is a free agent you
know offensive line plays crucial for
kyle shannon and how he plays you know
especially at that tackle position he
asked he asks of that position maybe
more than any in all of football because
of his creativity and everything he does
you're a left tackle not only get a pass
protect you got to be able to get up the
second level all the creative screens
the reverses the speed sweeps
trent williams
is the best left tackle in football for
my money right now so can they figure
out how to resign him and get him back
that would be you know that be the first
thing i would look at they have that
kyle use check who's kind of that hybrid
fullback tight end jack of all trades
guy i know shanahan loves those type of
football players i look at him but
overall the offense i think is in a good
spot the defense you like the front
seven when healthy special still it is
special the the to me the big thing for
the 49ers is they're secondary there's a
lot of question marks there there there
has to be
you know an improvement in talent and
depth and everything we don't think
sherman's going to be back jakwaski tark
the free agent uh
jason veretz there and played really
well but we know i mean his whole career
has been injured so that's the position
i look at as just a glaring you know
beaking red light or uh blinking red
light
i can confuse my speaking that's fine
speaking
but that's where i look at the their
that'll never show up again improvement
i'm sure i'm sure it won't but that's
where i look there their biggest
improvement needs to be done on their
football team
last week john lynch the gm of the team
said that
he has no doubt that jimmy garoppolo
will be the starter
in 2021 i think it's what he had to say
what are you taking here garoppolo or
the field as the week one starting
quarterback for the 49ers
right now
i'm going to take garoppolo
i'm going the only thing i look at that
just a
like jumps out to me as a possibility
with because i don't think they got
enough
ammo to get a desean watson without kind
of like ruining their team a little bit
to go get him
to me the one move that i still look out
to go jimmy g not the guy the guy
guaranteed yet
is the jets and sam darnold that would
be the only one and i don't know how the
49ers really feel about him
um but
sam donald i is a guy like we've talked
about i still have faith in i think he
can be an nfl starting quarterback i
think he'd fit that shanahan system
and the jets are in a very good spot at
number two right now and these damn
quarterbacks that i've been evaluating
they're damn good so i could see them
taking a quarterback and sam darnold
being available that's the last obstacle
i think jimmy g's camp will have to
overcome
uh for him to be the starter next year
would they take cousins if he was
available kirk cousins vikings
quarterback i think the vikings are not
going to trade him because he would need
an upgrade because cousins in this year
can help save jobs in minnesota but if
he was available would would kyle want
to grab him as an upgrade to jimmy
garoppolo i think we've been down this
road before cousin stays healthy that's
the difference he's better and he stays
healthy yeah
in my heart of hearts i would say yes if
again if they don't have to give up too
much and it's apples for apples type of
thing yeah i mean what you said right
there he's he stays healthy and he's
just better so uh that at least from my
evaluation standpoint and again i jimmy
g is is real good you can win football
games you can win the super bowl with
him especially with kyle shanahan
coaching you know i i do believe that
but that's you know a big gift like
we've talked about we'd hit it last week
so yes if it was apples to apples and
there wasn't have to given up too much
for the 49ers i think they would make
the trade for for jimmy or kirk cousins
they have got to get better backups
though we've talked about that nick
mullins no cj beathard no 100
no
no it's time to move on i think those
two guys have aged kyle shanahan more
than anything else the past couple of
years agreed he's got a lot more grays
i'll say that for sure and you're spot
on they got to they can't
roll the dice on a really good team
anymore on these underwhelming backup
quarterbacks
i i gotta think of ryan fitzpatrick and
andy dalton
uh mitch trubisky they gotta have a
legitimate backup quarterback this year
that is a known commodity that you know
at least has some talent and can win
some football games and at the very
least not mess them up like the other
two guys you just mentioned
i love the idea of trubisky going to san
francisco because it was the san
francisco pick that the bears used after
they traded up horizon 2 in the 2017
draft to get trubisky there's some
poetry to that possibility and
fitzpatrick it's come out recently that
he wants to go somewhere and compete to
be a starter look i i you know how i
feel about ryan fitzpatrick i think he's
great when he's used in the right
moments for the right doses when you
make him the guy you are just you're
setting the egg timer for that moment
where he has four interceptions and it
just falls apart and and if you know
when to put him in and when to put him
out and when to put him in and when to
put him out he can be very good
i don't know that any other team is
going to be looking for a relief pitcher
like the dolphins had with him and tua
last year
but i kind of would like him as the the
protection against jimmy garoppolo
either getting injured or
you know if garoppolo if garoppolo goes
out there and throws several
interceptable balls like he did in the
playoff game against the vikings maybe
if you got ryan fitzpatrick on the
sideline you you can send him in to get
your cookies out of the fire if things
are are looking bad one day well i i
that's the greatness of brian
fitzpatrick he doesn't care or battle
eye no matter what situation he's in you
know he's gonna understand the offense
and do those type of things and i i
agree with you one i don't think there's
gonna be any legit you know
play for him to be a starting
quarterback i would be shocked if he's
brought anywhere to compete and be that
but he is to me
the ultimate backup he really is you
know just he's played a lot he's got all
that experience he can make some plays
still off schedule and do those type of
things and he's one of the best i've
ever seen about oh i got to come off the
bench i haven't been doing anything for
three hours no big deal i'll just i'll
fling it around and make good decisions
and fire it in there i mean he is
capable of doing that so he from that
standpoint is is very you know
intriguing as a backup quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports